you know the situation on the ground is
dire there is no enough water there is
no enough food I've spoke to my mother
and my sister and they had to you know
to eat biscuits yesterday uh you know
because there is no enough food to go
around there's no toilets and they sleep
on the Sands because there are
difficulties sleeping on the buses as
well I would appeal to the Egyptian
government
um you know to maybe perhaps increase
the person on the ground to help you
know people who are literally escaping
with their life from the situation in
Sudan we've all been devastated uh about
the situation in Sudan my father as I
said didn't really want to leave but
seeing one of his neighbors dying from
bombardment uh when I I managed to speak
to him right after that and he was a
state of instead of shock and then he
was panicking
um he he is a retired surgeon as well
he's a 73 year old spent 20 of 20 years
of his life outside of Sudan and he went
back home and he did not want to leave
Sudan at all so I can I can tell that he
was heartbroken